Hi it's Michelle from Lab Muffin Beauty
Science: chemistry PhD and cosmetic science nerd.
A lot of you told me that
you really enjoyed  watching me get
tortured by watching a five-minute crafts
video, so I'm going to do it again for
your entertainment. Let my pain become
your pleasure. If you like this sort of
video you can subscribe to my channel,
you can click like, and you can follow me
on Instagram and my blog. If you have
suggestions for a video that I watch
that isn't 5 minute crafts, then please
drop it in the comments as well.
Today's video is "40 viral beauty hacks that will blow your mind" Now I expect there's a
little bit of exaggeration with the
title, but I will be very disappointed if
I am not virally mind-blown. Let's give
this a whirl. So this is a legitimate
nail art technique; I've used it before,
the only thing I'm a little bit worried
about is that it's a gel polish and I
believe because of the bottle it's light
protective you can see it's a black
bottle. It might be one that you need a
UV light to set. So the way one of these
UV gel polishes works is it contains
monomers, which after you expose to UV
light these monomers which are little
little molecules they will join together
to form a plastic. This plastic is called a
polymer. If you don't do this then the
smaller molecules can irritate your skin
it can cause nasty nasty allergic
reactions. You would have to set it with
UV after this I am almost certain they
haven't. So if you're going to do this
hack just use a normal nail polish with
it. If you really want to have that long
lasting UV gel effect, I would recommend
doing this with normal nail polish then
covering it with a clear UV topcoat and
then setting the topcoat with a UV lamp.
You can also use lots of different
sprays for the spraying part you can use
pretty much anything I've commonly seen
people use perfume for this I've never
personally used hairspray, though.
I mean obviously that's a fake pimple, it
looks more like a wart.
So the reason people crush up aspirin
and use it on their face is because
aspirin is acetylsalicylic acid
salicylic acid is beta hydroxy acid BHA
this is a really common treatment for
clearing out pores, it's a chemical
exfoliant. Acetylsalicylic acid, which is
an aspirin, this has what's called an
acetyl group (surprise) attached to the
hydroxy part of the molecule. It's not
really known whether or not it converts
effectively into salicylic acid on your
skin. It does convert in your digestive
tract. It still probably has
anti-inflammatory properties but it's
not really the same as salicylic acid,
you can't really cheap out and use this
and expect the same results. So I think
using a proper salicylic acid treatment
should work better but this isn't the
worst hack. There is also a slight
concern that if you use an aspirin
tablet and you just mix it with water
you're going to end up with a really
high concentration on your skin. So this
can be quite irritating on your skin
especially because it is still an acid
and so if you have this sort of
irritation it can lead to your pimple
lasting longer, it can lead to
hyperpigmentation, which might take a
while to fade. Again it's just safer to
use a proper salicylic acid product that
is made for applying on the skin.
Glitter near your eyes is usually not a
great idea. Depending on the type of
glitter, some glitters are made of little
flakes of metal. Metal is sharp, your eyes
are fragile, so if you get a tiny piece
of glitter in your eyes, which is quite
likely, if you've ever tried using a
really brightly colored eyeshadow you'll
see that it comes out in your tears, so
it is getting into your eye. If it gets
trapped under your eyelid, which again is
not that far-fetched, it can scratch your
cornea and then lead to infections. There
are a few case studies where people have
gotten glitter into their eyes and it
scratched it and it's led to nasty
infections which has led to permanent
damage. Petroleum jelly is not very good
at holding stuff onto your skin.
Petroleum jelly is greasy, it can be a
bit sticky, but around your eye area if
you wear this for any amount of time
because it's not made for keeping stuff
stuck, the glitter is probably going to
migrate. So sticking glitter near your
eye in something that's not made for
sticking is just a bad combination it's
a lot safer just to get a gold eyeliner
and draw on flex if you want that look
This isn't the worst hack. Pretty much
any oil will help out with dry hair.
I do think it's a waste of perfectly good
whipped cream.
I guess the whipped texture would make
it easier to distribute on your hair,
but you can do this with lots of different
oils: coconut oil, sunflower oil, olive oil.
I do recommend that you wash it out with
shampoo though because otherwise it can
get a bit greasy.
That seems like a waste of a perfectly
good lump of jelly. You really don't need
that much to cover your skin. Again I
don't think it's the worst hack but it
just seems like a bit of a waste. I do
like the fact that it does use gelatin,
but it doesn't get you to apply the
gelatin on your skin. When gelatin is applied
to your skin it turns into a pretty
solid film pretty quickly and removing
that is incredibly painful. I'm also not
sure the pomegranate tea will do much
pomegranate does contain antioxidants, in
tea form it's probably not quite as good
as fresh, but again having it in this
giant jelly lump the antioxidants just
probably aren't going to get to your
skin in any meaningful concentration.
I would recommend instead just making the tea and not adding gelatin. Just paint it
on your face as a mask and wash it off
afterwards. I don't think you'll be as
effective as a proper antioxidant mask,
but it's a lot less hassle and you'll
end up with probably a better effect
than this particular hack.
Activated charcoal is good for absorbing
odors; the way that it works is that it
has a really large surface area so it's
really good at grabbing on to things so
things like odors, so not a really
terrible hack. There is a bit of a risk
that activated charcoal could
potentially scratch your teeth. Activated
charcoal obviously also doesn't contain
fluoride which is pretty important for
hardening your teeth so if you
continually brush your teeth with just
activated charcoal it's not going to
harden your teeth and it could make you
more prone to cavities.
But I guess just the very act of
brushing your tongue, and removing some
of the bacteria in your mouth might help.
This seems like an incredibly roundabout
and damaging way to give yourself redder lips.
There are so many things that
will give you redder lips better.
Basically what this is doing is
irritating your lips so that there's
more blood flow to your lips and so it
becomes more pink. Long-term this sort of
irritation and inflammation can make
your lips age faster and of course
lipstick exists. If you really want to
get into this DIY thing you could also
just use berries, just berry juice is a
lovely red color that won't irritate
your lips anywhere near this much. And
another thing that irritates your lips
is just slapping yourself in the mouth,
just slap yourself in the mouth. These
craft things! This is where 5-minute
crafts is good! This is what they should
have always stuck to. Just stick things
together to make useful accessories it's
fun, it's a really great activity to do
with your kids, just stick to that.
Things that are safe for your eyes are not
necessarily safe for your lips.
A lot more can get through your lips because you are going to be eating with them as
shown in this video. You end up with a
lot more of lip products in your body.
Now, if they're purposely designed for
your lips this is generally safe, but if
they're designed for your eyes and you're
eating it, it's like eating anything else that is not.
It's just not a good idea.
And on top of this I'm not sure lash
gel will actually do this. Depends on
what lash gel you're using. I guess if
it's something more waterproof, like
clear mascara, it could work but most of
the time with the lash gels I've been
able to find they don't have any
waterproofing ingredients they look
mostly just like moisturizer. It would be
much more effective just to get a long-wear lipstick.
I think what they're trying to show here
is dark circles. Dark circles will not go
away that quickly and they will not go
away with tea bags. What tea bags can do
is reduce swelling from pooling of
liquid, so it can help contract the area
and tighten the skin temporarily, which
can push any liquid that's being
gathered around your eyes away. So when
you lie down at night you have lots of
liquid inside your body in between cells
and this liquid can sort of go from your
legs back into your face sort of like
you're a bottle of water lying down.
And so this can help your face look smoother because it plumps up your skin. When you
stand up during the day, gravity makes
this liquid go back towards your feet
and so your skin tends to look a bit
more wrinkled at night compared to when
you first wake up. So your eye bags will
also get swollen up after you lie down.
So cold tea bags can help push the
liquid out, but it's not going to work
for dark circles.
This hack will work. Oils will dissolve
things that water generally can't: things
like waterproof makeup oily foundations.
So this hack will work, it's pretty safe.
So I think I can safely say my mind was
not blown, I'm pretty disappointed about
that. I don't know what that definition
of a viral beauty hack is, I don't think
any of those were really that viral. I
guess five minute crafts is an
infectious virus in itself, so that ticks
that box...? I do think there are some
decent hacks in there that at the very
least are safe, but there's just enough
unsafe ones in there that I think it's
pretty irresponsible. I think most of us
realize it's irresponsible, but I think
there are probably a lot of teenagers
out there who would be tempted to try
these. I'm not sure of any ones being
hurt by anything five-minute crafts has
released. I do kind of feel that the only
way for them to stop is if they get sued.
Unfortunately, I think their business
model does depend on making really awful
hacks and that's pretty disturbing.
So yeah, I don't know if there's any real
way of disincentivizing these content
farms from making their sort of content.
I guess educating people on the problems
with these is a good start, but I feel
like, I guess information like this
terrible hacks have been around forever
so if you were alive in the 90's and early
2000's you'll know that there were email
forwards going around with awful, awful
hacks all the time.
But I think with our current media setup
this sort of thing tends to proliferate
a lot faster and it reaches a lot more
people. Anyway, I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did, please like it and
subscribe to my channel. You can also
click the notification bells to get
alerts when I put out new videos. You can
also follow me on Instagram
@labmuffinbeautyscience where I post lots
of beauty tips and sciencey information
You can also check out my blog labmuffin.com. I will see you next time
where I will hopefully be less tortured.